lorsque nous rencontrons yousline pour
la première fois une demandeuse d'asile
d'origine colombienne son bébé n'a que
10 jours elle habite temporairement dans
l'appartement d'une amie ils sont neuf
au total dans un Catherine à Montréal
Nord
entassés mais heureux
celle qui a accepté de les héberger
temporairement les dix est elle aussi
une demandeuse d'azel d'origine
colombienne et maire de deux enfants
elle est arrivée au Canada depuis plus
longtemps sa plus grande fille va déjà à
l'école
les enfants des deux familles s'adorent
même s'ils se côtoient depuis quelques
jours à peine
une semaine plus tard nous leur rendons
visite à nouveau l'entraide est toujours
palpable les deux familles ont parcouru
séparément de nombreux pays en partie en
avion mais aussi en autobus et parfois à
pied pour arriver jusqu'au Canada
quand Yacine a traversé le désert du
Mexique vers les États-Unis elle était
enceinte elle dit à voir fuit la
violence sa fille jellin 4 ans ne veut
pas retourner dans son pays d'origine
non parce qu'on tue beaucoup là-bas
et je ne veux pas mourir je veux rester
vivante dit-elle mais Lady le rat
annoncé récemment une mauvaise nouvelle
des voisins se sont pleins du bruit le
propriétaire a su qu'ils étaient neufs
dans l'appartement les 10 douleurs
demander de partir pour éviter des
ennuis
les vêtements qu'il transporte sont tous
des dons ils n'ont aucun meuble aucun
matelas de bouche à oreille ils ont
trouvé un chauffeur pour le transport à
travers ce bras le bas de combat les
enfants rient insouciants Jean-Pierre
disant dit même avoir hâte de voir sa
nouvelle maison
le lendemain et la famille nous fait
parvenir cette vidéo le problème pour
eux n'est pas qu'ils ont couché à 5 sur
des couvertures avec le bébé mais l'état
de l'appartement lorsque nous arrivons
sur les lieux Jonathan est déjà en
contact avec la gérante de l'immeuble
pour tenter de comprendre ce qui se
passe l'appartement qu'ils ont loué 1250
dollars par mois dans Côte des Neiges et
non seulement un propre mais il est
difficile d'y référer sans tousser même
après seulement 15 minutes
nous explique que le bébé vomit depuis
qu'ils sont arrivés il est d'ailleurs
malade devant nous lorsque la famille
est arrivée par le chemin Roxane en
décembre 2022 et là d'abord été hébergé
dans une chambre d'hôtel au frais du
fédéral car les refuges provinciaux
étaient plein or lorsque les migrants
passent par ces hôtels aucun travailleur
social ou intervenant ne leur ai attitré
à leur arrivée
la gérante de l'appartement leur dit de
ne pas s'en faire qu'elle leur prête un
autre appartement accessible en métro le
temps que les travaux n'ont celui-ci
soit terminé nous nous rendons avec eux
dans l'autre appartement cette fois du
quartier Saint-Michel
il se situe au sous-sol pour le reste
les images parlent d'elles-mêmes
comment avez-vous eu l'idée de nous
envoyer ici ma famille et moi dans ce
taudis demande Jonathan à la gérante
celle-ci se dit impuissante et
impossible de parler aux propriétaires
en ce jeudi soir tous les sites
d'hébergement pouvant accueillir une
famille son plein à Montréal reste des
refuges pour toxicoman
après deux trois heures de démarche de
multiples appels la famille apprend
qu'une place dans un centre
d'hébergement de Montréal Nord est libre
la famille est enfin au chaud et en
sécurité mais ce centre d'hébergement
pourrait fermer bientôt le propriétaire
de l'édifice vient d'émettre un avis de
non renouvellement du bail quant à la
famille nous avons décidé de continuer
de la suivre dans les prochaines
semaines ici Julie Marceau Radio-Canada
Montréal